les sirènes ici à odessa ont retenti
toute la nuit vous savez ces sirènes qui
préviennent d'une éventuelle frappe et
qui demande à la population de se mettre
à l'abri vous l'avez dit un damien hier
pour la première fois des missiles ont
été tirés en direction de cette grande
ville portuaire de la mer noire
plusieurs missiles au ont échoué dans la
mer mais l'un at atterri sur un immeuble
d'habitations faisant un blessé il ya
beaucoup de questionnements ici 1,2 de
la population qui se demande est bien
quand ça va tomber c'est vraiment une
appréhension en disant qu'ils
n'échapperont pas aux pilonnages russe
mais qui ne savent pas de quelle manière
cela se fera beaucoup pensé et bien que
vladimir poutine et la russie allait
attendre que milieu nicolas yves tombes
étaient très encouragés du fait que et
bien les soldats ukrainien résister
considérablement amicaux live et
réussissait à repousser le front et puis
les premières frappes hier en direction
de dessin alors que mikko live n'est pas
encore tombé font craindre le pire ici à
la population dont beaucoup
d'appréhension à odessa tully bonjour
vous êtes rendu hier avec amar alameda
week et derrière la caméra en ce moment
dans ce dernier verrou avant odessa dont
vous parliez à l'instant la ville de
nicolet iv les jambes vous avez
rencontré les habitants vous ont décrit
une atmosphère extrêmement pesante
oui c'est une atmosphère vraiment très
pesant toute la journée les sirènes ont
retenti dans la ville nous avons pu voir
des femmes notamment courir pour se
mettre à l'abri puis à plusieurs frappes
ont touché la ville hier nous avons pu
nous rendre notamment dans le
centre-ville de nicolas yves une heure
après une frappe aérienne qui a détruit
un immeuble cet immeuble qui abritait
alors un hôtel et une banque un les
immeubles à côté ont également été
endommagés le gardien de cet hôtel qui
était seul présent sur place a été
blessé d'autres sites ont été tous
touchés et également comme un hôpital
psychiatrique ou encore et bien des
infrastructures en banlieue de la ville
sans précisions quant à la nature de ces
bâtiments j'ai pu m'entretenir avec de
nombreuses personnes sur place notamment
une femme dans une tension un lieu de
résidences d'habitation à qui m'a
interpellé depuis le sous sol d'un
immeuble quand elle a vu que nous étions
en train film et elle m'a dit qu'elle
vivait dans ce sous sol depuis un mois
qu'elle était terrorisée elle n'avait
pas de mots assez durs pour qualifier la
lumière poutine le comparant à satan
j'ai pu m'entretenir également avec
amara la médaille avec les pompiers de
la ville qui était encore en train est
bien de dégager et décors du du de
l'infrastructure militaire qui avait été
touché à vendredi avec plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines de soldats ukrainien
qui t'ont et qui ont été tués c'est
jeune homme aux traits tirés me
décrivait à l'enfer qu'ils vivaient
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines un
jeune homme me disait eh bien qu'ils
n'auraient jamais pensé voir quelque
chose de tel au 21ème siècle donc
beaucoup d'appréhension amicaux life ces
gens regardent bien entendu les images
de marioupol et ont une grande crainte
c'est que ils soient les prochains sur
la liste